You know guys at its core, CS:GO is a tactical game.
In-game leaders and coaches spend countless hours coming up with a myriad of strats for each
and every single map.
But sometimes it's the little stuff that can trip you up.
Like not buying a defuser, or burning to death in your own molly.
(Casting)
And so here we are with the top 10 misplays in CS:GO.
Kicking off this list is team KKona’s inVert at CEVO Pro League Season 9.
In a match that was already going to live
on in infamy
(Stream)
inVert found himself in a 1v2 situation with the bomb planted at B. While setting up his
defense, he tossed a molly onto window, and the rest is just… well, tragic.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 9 is Team Liquid’s Koosta at ELEAGUE Season 1.
In a tight 2v2 situation against C9, Koosta found himself with the bomb as time ticked away.
All he had to do was plant it within 4 seconds, but then, this happened.
(Casting)
Making its way in at number 8 is SK Gaming’s semifinal match against Ninjas in Pyjamas
at IEM Oakland 2017.
Having found an early lead, the Brazilians looked to widen the gap even further
if only they had just defused the bomb.
Let this be a lesson in just how critical communication is at Counter-Strike’s highest level.
(Casting)
When you’re already down 13-2 at the half and 0-2 in the group stage, a team kill is
definitely not what you need to turn things around.
That’s why CaptainMo of TyLoo earns our number 7 spot on this list.
Taking on G2 at IEM Oakland 2016, TyLoo desperately needed something to rally around, but that
thing was not a team kill.
We could say more about this play, but we’re going to let Semmler take it from here.
(Casting)
At the number 6 spot is Magiskboy, whose North squad were taking on SK Gaming at ESL One
Cologne 2017.
Down 15-10 on Cache, Magisk had the perfect opportunity to extend the map by planting
the bomb after taking out TACO.
Instead, this play serves as a PSA for just how big of a roll movement plays in a game of CS:GO.
(Casting)
It brings us no pleasure to inform you that number 5 marks Koosta’s second appearance
on this list, this time as a amember of Counter Logic Gaming at Dreamhack Valencia 2017
With CLG on the cusp of advancing to the playoffs, Koosta was the one tasked with the defuse
and everyone watching thought that everything was wrapped up.
Except it wasn’t.
Just take a look at FNS’ face, the man who actually had the defuse kit.
(Casting)
Oh yeah, CLG ended up losing the series in overtime.
Coming in hot at number 4 is Cloud9 at ESL ESEA Pro League Season 1 Finals.
During the summer of 2015, the North American squad were on a tear, making three consecutive
grand finals and beating out multiple European
juggernauts in the process.
But even when you’re the best from NA, you’re still NA.
At the tail end of the sixth round on Overpass against Fnatic, Cloud9 just needed to defuse
the bomb to win.
But I have no words to describe what happened
next.
(Casting)
Coming in at Number 3 is CajunB with Astralis at the MLG Columbus Major.
While the Danes were trailing in the first half of their semi final match against Natus Vincere,
Cajunb & co got a lucky break when Na’Vi left themselves no time to plant the bomb.
All CajunB to do was stay alive.
His reaction says the rest.
(Casting)
You had one job Cajunb.
One job.
Despite winning the ELEAGUE Atlanta Major, Xyp9x takes the runners up spot on our list
in a quarterfinal match against Na’Vi.
Na’Vi were on map point in round 30 of Game #2.
Being the clutch master that he is, Xyp9x waited patiently in a 1v2 and caught seized
and Edward right where he wanted them.
That is, if he hadn’t forgotten to line up his shots.
(Casting)
Hopping off the bomb at number 1 is Ex6tenz at ASUS ROG Winter 2015.
Down a map against NiP, Titan’s in-game leader was looking to bring the French squad
to match point.
And in a 1v1 against NiP’s Maikelele, all Ex6tenz had to do was hold the defuse.
But with the pressure of the grand final, anything can happen.
(Casting)
Well guys, that's our list for this week. Now if you didn't already know we put out great content each
and every week on this channel, and if you're not subbed yet. Well, that's the real misplay.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.